У доповіді німецької розвідки на семи сторінках зазначено, що проти української армії воюють,
як мінімум, дві правоекстремістські групи: "Імперський легіон" та "Русич".
Вони відомі тим, що вже воювали на Донбасі у 2014-му та 2015-му роках, відрізнялися тоді особливою жорстокістю і, як правило, не брали полонених.
"Імперський легіон" - це воєнізований підрозділ ультраправого об'єднання "Російський імперський рух",
яке включено у США та Канадi до списку терористичних організацій. Ось що про це відомо експертам.
"Російський імперський рух" переважно походить з Санкт-Петербурга, де підтримував дуже тісні зв'язки з петербурзьким відділенням партії "Родіна".
Вони разом організували різноманітні заходи, намагалися розвивати навіть міжнародні відносини.
Лідер "Російського імперського руху" навіть був у Відні кілька років тому, виступав на консервативній платформі,
але, наскільки я розумію, навряд чи йому це вдасться зробити знову.
Вони кілька років тому організовували гітарний табір під назвою "Партизан" десь у Ленінградській області.
І туди запрошували навіть іноземних ультраправих активістів.
І так сталося, що двоє активістів, які проходили підготовку в цьому таборі, після повернення до Швеції влаштували серію терактів.
Чи можна говорити про якийсь серйозний вплив неонацистів на хід війни в Україні чи про їхню високу чисельність?
Експерти так не вважають. Попри спроби вербувати прихильників, максимум може йтися про сотні людей.
Під час війни на Донбасі у 2014-15 роках вони грали значно більшу роль.
Вони були у значно більшій кількості у 14-15 роках, коли Російська Федерація покладалася саме на добровольців,
які були готові їхати на схід України та воювати.
Для того, щоб створити певну видимість, що це воюють не російські війська, а місцеві, начебто ці сепаратисти, яких часто називали ополченцями.
Ось тоді була в них більша потреба, ніж зараз.
Зараз там теж є якісь добровольці, але здебільшого це, звісно, таки російські війська.
І все ж таки сам факт участі у війні неонацистів з російського боку "робить абсурдною уявну причину війни, так звану "денацифікацію" України"
- зазначено в доповіді німецької розвідки.
Попри те, що обидві сторони регулярно використовують терміни "фашизм" та "нацизм",
ця ідеологія не відіграє особливої ролі у війні, зазначає Антон Шеховцов.
Взагалі сама ідея денацифікації, вона від початку абсурдна.
І я б наполягав на тому, що це не війна фашистів чи антифашистів з того чи іншого боку.
Фашисти тут взагалі ніде жодної ролі ані з того, ані з іншого боку не грають.
Те, що були завжди ультраправі на боці Російської Федерації - це факт.
Те, що ультраправі були на боці України, також факт. Але це не стосується суті, природи цієї війни.
Вона не має відношення саме до якоїсь ультраправої ідеології.
З деякими застереженнями, але ми можемо говорити про якусь імперіалістичну війну.
Але, знову ж таки, з деякими застереженнями, але це не ідеологічна війна, скажімо, фашизму проти антифашизму.
Тут взагалі фашизм треба винести за дужки, він нічого не пояснює і, зрештою, нічого не вирішує.
Про те, що відомо уряду Німеччини про неонацистів у лавах російської армії, DW запитала на урядовій конференції у Берліні.
Втім, там зазначили, що не коментують повідомлення спецслужб.